un monsieur nous avions fait dans les
formes monsieur le président sur un
écran et inaugurer une nouvelle forme de
conférence de presse mais je me réjouis
qu'il soit aujourd'hui arrive on est en
présence
macron est le premier invité étranger
que nous accueillons au bundestag
cette année et c'est un bon 6 milliards
cela montre que nous avons sont dans la
lutte contre la pandémie en france comme
en allemagne
les taux d'incidence baisse nous avons
fait de grands progrès dans la
vaccination
nous avons atteint les 50%
aujourd'hui il ya trois ans il ya cru et
moi même nous sommes rencontrés et avait
fait une déclaration commune en faveur
de la défense du bien-être de la
prospérité plus résistantes
bien que n'ayant pas encore atteint tous
nos objectifs concernant la migration
nous avons bien progressé et nous avons
également rendu l'europe plus forte au
niveau de la sécurité
il nous préparer dès aujourd'hui pour la
réunion du conseil européen des 24 et 25
juin au cours de laquelle nous parlerons
des politiques étrangères de
souveraineté européenne notamment
vis-à-vis de la russie et de la turquie
il s'agit également de tirer des
enseignements de la pandémie appris que
la l'europe doit agir
de manière unie il faut également
pouvoir réagir plus rapidement et rendre
la société privée plus résistantes
nous devons rester vigilants concernant
la propagation des variants ou des
mutations comme nous pouvons voir et je
pense que nous sommes d'accord sur ce
sujet jeudi ou vendredi nous parlerons
bien et la russie et de la turquie
nous avons tous les deux rencontré le
président erdogan lors du sommet de
l'otan
nous sommes entretenus avec lui et nous
savions que nous faisons face à de
grands défis
il ya des divergences d'opinion des
pignons sur certains sujets des points
communs sur d'autres par exemple sur la
question de la migration et sur des
questions de l'avenir la question des
relations que la russie est également
une question majeure
la russie représente un défi pour nous
c'est également notre grand voisin
continental devant être certain de
rester en contact avec que nous
souhaitons s'ils le souhaitent à la
stabilité en europe
il faut rester un dialogue avec la
russie même si cela est compliqué le
président américain joe biden a
rencontré vladimir poutine
ils ont tué un dialogue très ouverte et
nous pouvons également faire la même
chose au niveau européen afin de pouvoir
traiter 1 au point de vue divergents et
notamment évoqué la question de
l'ukraine afin de donner une chance au
processus de musc protocole de minsk de
pouvoir arriver à son terme
je me réjouis de l' échange avec
manuel macron et je souhaite vous
remercier monsieur le président encore
une fois pour votre présence que vous
donnez la parole
chéreng et là mesdames messieurs je me
réjouis en effet de revenir en allemagne
près d'un an après ma dernière visite à
meseberg nous avons été séparés par la
pandémie
mais nos échanges sont restés nourrit
régulier pendant sept années à distance
comme l'a rappelé madame la chancelière
avec en particulier plusieurs un conseil
franco allemand de défense et de
sécurité
récemment un conseil des ministres
franco-allemand et plusieurs dialogues
technologie que nous avions décidé de
lancer ensemble à la fin de l'été
dernier on nous retrouvons à brégançon
d'abord je vais ici dire que en effet
ensemble nous allons continuer de bâtir
des résultats l'année dernière a amusé à
berck vous venez de le rappeler nous
avions pris des décisions fortes sur le
plan de la relance économique et de
l'instauration d'un dialogue de
prospérité de protection de l'europe
s'en sont suivis à la fois un plan de
laurent de relance européen et une
dynamique importante sur le plan
d'ailleurs de défense comme le la
technologie européenne
cette coordination franco allemande on
l'a aussi retrouvé à l'oeuvre lors des
sommets du g7 et de l'otan que nous
venons de vivre où nous avons ensemble
pu définir une ligne européenne fait de
responsabilité de cohérence avec les
sujets que nous défendons mais celle qui
consiste à défendre nos valeurs à les
inscrire dans la coopération avec nos
alliés ou les grandes puissances
économiques et démocratiques avec
lesquels nous coopérons mais aussi avec
les préférences européennes qui sont les
nôtres nous allons en effet comme madame
la chancelière vient de le rappeler ce
soir discuter de la préparation du
prochain conseil européen de la semaine
prochaine dont l'ordre du jour sera
dense je partage tout ce qui a été dit
aussi bien sur la turquie que la russie
nous aurons en effet à revenir sur nos
relations avec la turquie en cohérence
avec les conditions que nous avions posé
pour rétablir une relation de confiance
en mars dernier en prenant en compte
évidemment en premier chef les intérêts
de d'états membres de l'union que sont
la grèce et chypre et notre position
stratégique en méditerranée orientale
aux proches moyen-orient libye ou dans
la région du caucase
nous aurons aussi à revenir sur le sujet
de la russie afin de réfléchir à une une
grammaire communes régissant nos
relations avec notre voisin pour réagir
de manière solidaire aux provocations
mais surtout dessiné les voies d'une
coopération exigeante nous sommes
confrontés en effet à des provocations
régulière a aussi une nouvelle conflit
tu alité mais nous sommes je crois
pouvoir le dire l'un et l'autre
conscients de la nécessité de trouver
des règles communes de relations avec la
russie
nous traiterons aussi des relations
entre l'union européenne et les états
tiers de la méditerranée afin de
coopérer plus efficacement dans le
domaine des migrations pour éviter d'une
part les drames en mer durant l'été mais
pouvoir aussi entamé une approche
complète du sujet si important des
migrations qui nous a beaucoup occupé
ces dernières années et dont nous sommes
convaincus qu'il implique une approche
d'ensemble pour que les éléments de
solidarité et de responsabilité soient
prises en compte par tous les états
qu'ils soient et à de premier accueil
état de deuxième destination comme
d'ailleurs à l'allemagne et la france le
sont fortement ou états qui doivent
montrer une une forme de solidarité pour
gérer le sujet le conseil nous permettra
par ailleurs de faire le point au plan
interne sur la réouverture de nos
sociétés et de nos économies après la
pandémie nous partageons à la fois la
même vigilance sur la situation actuelle
la même conviction que la réponse se
fera dans la durée par plus de
coopération entre l'allemagne et la
france est entre européens et qu'au fond
nous sortons de cette crise avec la
conviction qu'il faut plus de réactivité
dans l'organisation de la puissance
publique et dans la relation avec le
secteur privé et plus de résilience dans
nos économies à notre organisation
collective
nous ferons aussi un point sur le plan
de relance européen qui se déploie
rapidement dans nos pays
ces derniers jours ont d'ailleurs montré
la mise en oeuvre concrète de ce que
nous avions décidé il ya un an
enfin cette séquence de travail
permettra aussi d'avancer sur plusieurs
sujets bilatéraux
en particulier nous avons acté en fin
d'été dernier une volonté renforcée
d'avancé sur plusieurs investissements
productifs ensemble nous avons engagé un
travail stratégique nouveau bilatérale à
la fois ensemble avec nos ministres en
associant étroitement la commission
européenne et les industriels des
différents secteurs concernés mais nous
avons décidé de lancer des projets
communs en matière de micro électronique
de spatiale de mobilité d'hydrogène de
santé de cloud qui nous ont permis de
structurer en particulier des projets
des financements comme un européen mais
des coopérations forte sur le plan de la
recherche et de la technologie entre nos
deux pays
nous avons aussi réussi à consacrer
durant ces dernières semaines des
avancées significatives sur les projets
lancés ensemble à l'été 2010 est tout
particulièrement pour le scaf et donc le
l'avion du futur mais les projets
avancent aussi sur notre char de combat
commun c'est donc une session de travail
riche qui nous attend avec aussi cette
volonté de continuer à montrer que le
couple franco-allemand agi avec d'une
part le respect de tous les partenaires
européens mais la volonté d'améliorer
aussi de manière très concrète la vie de
nos concitoyens
en tout cas à chéreng et la madame la
chancelière merci beaucoup de nous faire
l'honneur de cette réouverture des
invitations aujourd'hui à berlin
bonsoir
sophie la crise de la lfp monsieur le
président madame lachance hilaire une
question sur la défense européenne la
france a beaucoup prêcher le
renforcement de l'autonomie stratégique
de l'ue à l'avènement d'une véritable
défense européenne est ce qu'avec le
retour dans le jeu des états unis la
relance de l'otan souhaitait par joe
biden et le le renforcement de lax
washington berlin qui se décident est ce
que tout ça n'est pas caduc
est ce que la france ne se sent pas un
petit peu isolé et une question sur
l'avenir du pacte de stabilité
il est suspendu jusqu'en 2023
quid de la suite la france plaide pour
sa réforme le parti de la chancelière
souhaite qu'ils soient réintroduits tel
qu'il était jusqu'au auparavant voilà
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire que
le président des états unis a créé un
climat de coopération ou au sein duquel
chacun peut jouer et doit jouer son rôle
mais la coopération ne signifie pas que
nous ayons pas chacun nos
responsabilités et je ne pense pas qu'il
y a une relation paris washington par la
machine tonnes est plutôt une relation
sein de l'otan nous savons
revue des devoirs qui sont liés à la
politique de sécurité européenne qui se
rajoute à la collaboration dans le cadre
de l'otan les états unis d amérique sont
unis ne veulent qu'une relation
pacifique et transatlantiques mais donne
se réorienter vers le pacifique cela
nous est clair cela signifie pour les
européens que nous devons reprendre des
responsabilités
nous devons renforcer les capacités en
commun cela signifie donc lancer des
projets tel que l'a souligné le projet
de sf ou d'autres à l'avenir
c'est une priorité absolue
nous devons agir de manière cohérente
devant étudier ce que nous pouvons faire
ce que nous devons faire et il faut être
plus préparé que dans le sol aujourd'hui
s'agissant du pacte de stabilité
nous ne sommes pas d'accord en fonction
de la situation actuelle nous avons
besoin d'investissements et le retour au
pacte de stabilité et la question de
cette forme du pacte de stabilité sera
évoquée dans à l'avenir aussi rapidement
que possible le plan de relance que nous
avions déjà évoqué à mes yeux pers est
également un élément important dans
cette optique nous avons déjà évoqué
tous les
et les gens de ce plan les attribuait
les puces électroniques
tout cela nécessite des investissements
que l'europe peut consentir en collectif
et cela est l'objectif d'un projet
européen centré sur les projets
importants en europe et par exemple
s'agissant de la production de batteries
ou dans le domaine de l'eau et c'est sur
le sujet de la défense européenne de ce
concept d'autonomie stratégique de
l'union européenne je constate d'abord
maintenant qu'il est rentré dans le
vocabulaire commun des européens ensuite
je note que le président byden lui même
publiquement et lors de notre rencontre
lors du sommet de l'otan a reconnu et je
pense que nous devons nous en réjouir
son respect à l'égard de l'union
européenne sur le plan politique et sa
volonté de travailler avec l'union
européenne comme un partenaire et donc
je pense que nous avons réussi à
installer l'idée que une défense
européenne et un autonomie stratégique
de l'union européenne n'était pas un
projet alternatif à l'organisation
transatlantique mais bien une composante
solide de celle ci
celle par laquelle les européens
reconnaissent qu'ils sont à part à
prendre leur part d'investissement et à
assurer leur part de sécurité commune en
particulier pour ce qui est de leur
voisinage et donc je partage que madame
la chancelière vient d'évoquer c'est à
dire que nous devons avant tout nous
réjouir de ce réengagement américain
parce qu'il permet de parachever un
travail stratégique que nous avions
lancée en décembre 2019
celui du nouveau concept de l'otan et
d'avoir un partenaire
première manquée est engagé et
deuxièmement qui croient à la
coopération et au multilatéralisme et
nous avons pu le constater lors du
sommet du g7 également donc je pense
qu'il ne faut pas voir le retour le
réengagement américain dans cette
stratégie de coopération comme la fin
d'une prise de conscience salutaire des
européens que leur destin dépend aussi
de même cet équilibre nous rendra
d'ailleurs plus fort pour ce qui est du
pacte de stabilité vous avez
bien dit vous même qu'il est suspendu
jusqu'en 2023 ce qui montre que nous
avons d'ailleurs collectivement
l'ensemble des institutions à l'oeuvre
pris nos responsabilités et réagit vite
compte tenu des situations
extraordinaires de la crise d'abord pour
suspendre évidemment des textes
budgétaires qui n'étaient plus
applicables
ensuite pour prendre les décisions
monétaires pour ce qui est de la bce qui
s'imposait je le dis parce que ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas lors des crises
la réaction a été adaptée rapide et a
permis justement à l'ensemble de
l'europe de tenir maintenant la priorité
n'est pas un débat sur le pacte
budgétaire la priorité elle est de
mettre en oeuvre le plan de relance que
nous avons 10 qui nous discuter et
décider ensemble il ya un an de le
déployer et de procéder aux bons
investissements qui vont nous permettre
de construire la croissance future et je
dirais que pour moi nous ne devons avoir
qu'un objectif s'est retrouvé la
trajectoire d'avant crise
nous savons désormais que durant les
premiers mois de l'année 2022
vraisemblablement si les chiffres se
confirment nous retrouverons chiffres de
croissance mais nous faut retrouver la
trajectoire de croissance d'avant crise
ce qui suppose des investissements ce
qui suppose une politique en faveur
justement de l'offre et de la création
d'emplois c'est la priorité
à date
j'ai une question s'adressant à la
chancelière comme au président
concernant le sujet du coronavirus vous
avez évoqué le variant delta qui se
répand en france il est déjà un
confident partiel au portugal il a la
même situation pourrait se répéter
donc nous aimerions savoir quels sont
pour l'avenir l'europe pourrait-elle
réagir de concert et il est une bonne
idée d'avoir une coupe de football
c'est le royaume uni la france a
remporté le match donc peut-être qu
emmanuel macron pourrait répondre à
prendre notre amitié nous avons échangé
après le dernier match est certaine la
france a battu la mannschaft dans ce
premier match de poule mais c'est une
équipe que nous respectons profondément
et nous avons suffisamment perdu deux
matches pour rester humble et concentrés
en ce début de compétition
écoutez je pense que les organisateurs
sont très vigilants et nous serons
évidemment en lien avec eux pour que les
conditions soient les meilleurs les tous
nos joueurs et nos équipes sont comme
vous le savez dans des bulles sanitaires
c'est à dire qu'ils ont été isolés
tester bien avant ainsi que l'ensemble
de leurs staffs donc pour ce qui est de
nos équipes
les précautions sont prises la question
qui va se poser d'ici la finale va
évidemment être pour les supporters et
d'encadrement et les conditions nous
avons pris d'ailleurs l'allemagne comme
la france des règles relativement
strictes pour ne pas dire strictes à
l'égard de la grande-bretagne depuis le
retour du variant enfin depuis pardon la
montée du variant indien
d'abord à date nous surveillons l'un
comme l'autre les choses que nous sommes
à peu près à la même proportion de
variants dit delta d'ailleurs il faut
plutôt employer ce terme pour nos
français personne je pensais plus
respectueux le variant delta représente
environ 6% de des formes de virus qui
sont observés dans nos pays donc nous le
maîtrisons nous sommes évidemment très
vigilants à toutes les formes
d'importation et donc nous continuons
d'exiger d'abord des motifs impérieux
pour ce qui est de venir en france ce
qui limite beaucoup les venues des
ressortissants britanniques vers la
france aujourd'hui elles sont
extrêmement limitées et nous imposons en
effet soit la vaccination soit des tests
pcr pour nos ressortissants lorsqu'ils
lorsqu'ils reviennent donc il ya
beaucoup de contraintes qui sont mis sur
les ressortissants britanniques pour
rejoindre en tout cas le sol français je
sais que c'est la même chose pour pour
l'allemagne ce que nous allons discuter
au conseil prochain et qui est ce que
nous plaidons l'année l'autre c'est de
renforcer la coordination de nos
politiques
et ce qui est vrai c'est que ces choix
sont des choix qui demeure nationaux
mais nous plaidons pour que la la
coordination soit plus forte et certains
états membres ont en effet ouvert plus
vite et plus fort que nous certaines
certains échanges pour des raisons
largement touristique et ce qui nous met
évidemment dans une situation de grande
vigilance
donc nous allons plaider pour que il ya
une homogénéisation des règles sur la
base justement de ce que nous proposons
sinon nous continuerons de toutes façons
d'être vigilant comme nous l'avons
toujours été pour éviter de réimporter
des formes de variants que nous arrivons
à maîtriser sur notre sol
nous avons renforcé la coordination mais
elle n'est pas encore parfaite l'avait
déjà évoqué lors du dernier conseil
européen
il ya des différences de régime qu'il a
vécue traitement du royaume uni je suis
d'accord nous avons des règles très
strictes mais il est certain que la
coordination été largement renforcées
par exemple il ya des conditions
concernant la vaccination ou détestent
la situation change en permanence
nous ne savons pas ce qui va arriver
dans un pays en fonction du taux de
vaccination ne savons pas comment va se
passer l'été ce grand peut dire que le
variant delta est trop agressif pour
pouvoir espérer maintenir le taux
d'incidence actuel s'il se répandait
suivons de près les foyers et je pense
que l'on peut encore éviter le variant
data il ne faut pas prétendre que le
coronavirus a disparu on a l'impression
avec l'arrivée de l'été que la situation
se porte mieux mais il ya encore
beaucoup de personnes vaccinées
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il faut
continuer d'être prudent avec un été
avec beaucoup de liberté mais pas toutes
les libertés
et c'est une très bonne chose par
exemple qu'avec des gens et puis se
rassembler
mais je reste un peu sceptique quand
ainsi c'est la bonne réaction face à la
situation actuelle
merci beaucoup
je
[Musique]